and you even describe you said I was
going to learn comedy I found Ivan wman
who was a great director of comedies I
went to Milton Burl the comedian and had
him train me in comedy Milton Burl was
you know a really funny guy and uh so he
was laughing about it of course and he
was making a joke because he of course
comes from Germany too he comes from his
name is actually Berlin was his name and
they shortened it when he came over here
to Burl and so uh so he he knows the
German background that's why I went to
him because he's aware of the
difficulties of Germans or austrians
kind of adapting to the American humor
so I asked him for help to kind of help
me with the timing and with order and to
write some jokes for me for speeches and
stuff like that and he was very happy to
take on the whole thing he always was
running around says God damn it I have
to teach this [__] Nazi some just
some jokes here this is like impossible
to do God damn it and he always cursed
and it's just really really funny but he
was so loving and so so nice and uh he
would go sit in the front row when I
give a speech somewhere and then he
would come up to me afterwards and says
you know the timing was off I said I
told you when you go out there to say
this is wonderful to get this award you
have no idea you know as a bodybuilder
of course you get medals and you get you
know troph off and you get Awards I said
but this award is the most
recent he says why do you say most
recent Arnold why don't you just say
most and then you get emotional wait a
little bit people didn't wait then you
say reent don't blow the line right away
have a little this the timing is so
important he says such a stupid
bodybuilding idiot mother and he would
just curse again in and just you know
then we would go go back and rehearse so
he would he will actually work with me
on the timing with the chokes and uh
that was very important to him and so I
learned a lot from Milton bur and I love
that he really was interested in helping
me